so last night I ran into Conan out to
dinner yep it was like a Kier enthusiasm
I mean k Kirby enthusiasm there all
these scenarios where you run into
celebrities in in Hollywood and it I
witnessed it last night it was with
Jimmy Kimmel yep Martin Short yep we run
into Conan y with Phil Rosenthal yep
Scott Ian from Anthrax Scott Ian from
Anthrax and his his lovely wife and uh
and it was Patton Oswald yep and his uh
wife Meredith and um and your wife yeah
and my wife wife Liza so uh I it's one
of those things that I'm on an I'm
getting on an airplane I was in Chicago
to interview the uh the Nirvana fellas
uh Nova selich and Gro and then I'm
flying back and I'm getting on the plane
and uh this gentleman with a fascinating
beard gets on sits opposite me and I'm
like oh I know who this is and he says
to me hi con and Scott Ian Anthrax I
played on your show and I went oh cool
so we chat the entire way about the
metal but also going back to punk
Ramon's uh his childhood uh it would
have been almost a great podcast just
chatting with him across the aisle and
then he said hey I'm good friends with
Patton and I'm like yeah I know I I'm
texting with Patton all the time I've
known Paton Oswald forever the next
thing I know there's one of those text
chains where it's like a dinner is
happening and I keep thinking um is this
ever going to happen and then finally
the day arrives November 1st we're going
to go out to this uh dinner so we go out
we're there we're having a really good
time and then uh the next thing I know
these figures are looming over us at our
table and it's it's you uh Mr Kimmel and
uh uh and uh Mr short Marty Short and
then we all get up and then we're all
standing in the middle of the restaurant
pretty much doing bits and
stuff yeah well Conan leaned into me and
he goes you're coming on the podcast
tomorrow just remember it's about me
mhm yeah no I did yeah true story yeah
and then sure enough and then he shows
up and then he shows up with questions
uh I know I love that he's done homework
this is prepared um oh this is my this
is my big question so when we do our
podcast we have the we have the
interview and then the moment the person
leaves after we're been like that was
great that was was going to be wonderful
and then they leave and they go what'
you think so my question is like this
time or last time that I was on what's
going to be the thing you say when I
leave what's going to be the real dirt
and I want to know the real thing okay
well first of all we have to get to the
end before we know that yeah because um
can we Circle back to it yeah of course
I'm already on board because he has my
mug so I'm I think this is a great
interview thanks well also I'm gonna I'm
gonna say something I love it when a
guest comes in uh I'm a huge fan of
yours you know that
and uh a big admirer of what you've
accomplished and what you've been able
to carve out for yourself but I also
love that you came in um and you're so
proactive that you're you're stirring it
up you're asking us questions that to me
makes for a better podcast I love that
so already ambitious ambitious came with
an agenda yeah um is it because it makes
it more about you though is that what
you mean yes yeah I think so I think
that makes me happy and uh in advance I
followed Matt and Sona on Instagram also
God bless one of them may have followed
me back I'm going to do it now not sure
do you remember last time that you
popped back on the zoom yeah that's is
that why you bring this up no okay yeah
cuz you we recorded over Zoom last time
and you po back in the zoom yeah while
we were doing our download so I like
this this is great I wasn't gone and you
got kept talking no we will um we'll
give you a full assessment afterwards
we'll be honest about it uh I have to
say and it's one of the reasons I really
love doing the podcast um over the years
of doing a late night show and uh I'm
just going to remind viewers that Mr
biglia when you were a young lad started
out as an intern on our show in the 9s
in the '90s um and he was an intern on
the program and then all these years
when we were at Rock fer Center the old
show and then um it's kind of cool to
contrast that was a show where I would
talk to multiple people a night
uh and you had so it was a volume
business and there in the postmortem we
really would sometimes get into it oh
yeah about oh my God can you believe
what that guest did can you say any of
them I don't like to hurt people I I
really don't I really
don't feeling you been doing to us for
years now well this is familiarity
breeds contempt so I know you guys I see
you every day so I have no fear um but
you know what's funny is about my
interning on your shows and part of the
reason that I became a standup comedian
is because of interning on your show so
like for example I would ask Mike
Sweeney and Brian stack and all these
writers for the show how would one
become a writer for Late Night with
Conan O'Brian because that's what I want
to do that's my dream and they and their
answers were I did standup I did improv
I went back to college did stand up an
improv and I did stand up I was like all
right this going pretty
well
that's all right better than pretty
well I think it went spectacularly go
well for a while though I mean it went
okay now it's good
um no I was always surprised by the
number of people that would come up to
me and say I'm really interested in
doing what you're doing and I would say
oh you know well what are you doing like
are you writing comedy are you um are
you in an improv troop are you doing
standup what are you doing and they be
like oh no I'm not doing any of that I
just want to
do give it to me yeah I would like that
when you're when you're done with it and
um but but I would say the
podcast it is I mean I'm hardpressed to
think of a podcast where I haven't
enjoyed talking to the people because we
don't make nearly as many of them and if
there's someone I don't want to talk to
I just don't talk to them and so it's it
uh it it feels like a really nice I I I
don't think I think it's I'm hardpressed
to think of a time when someone's left
here and I've thought boy I really
disliked talking to that person I
usually feel like I learned something
and also like I feel like it lets you do
goofball things without it feeling out
of place cuz it's much longer than like
a f minute interview like the hardest I
one of the hardest I've ever left at
this podcast I don't remember which
episode The Yoo episode oh yo yo yo it's
lots of fun to do if you like it holla
yay and if you don't you holla boo can
you give context people who didn't hear
that originally yeah okay will it was my
grandfather had some old like 45s in the
attic and we found one and it was this
singer in like the 50s singing a song
called yay boo yay boo and I remembered
once it's I can do it now on the podcast
and it feels like it's in place there
was one night on the on the Late Night
show when I'm out there and I'm really
just at this point I've done like 35,000
hours of Television but I'm in I'm doing
the monologue in the late night show for
NBC and I said something and the
audience mock went and then I said of
course someone so in the news the
audience went boo and I went yay boo yay
boo it's lots of fun to do if you like
it holla yay and if you don't holla boo
and I remember my producer my R everyone
was like what the was that but that
goes back to what you're saying of like
people come up to you and they go like I
want to do what you do and people say
that to me as a standup all the time and
I'm like you got to do it so many hours
like you're saying that you don't even
notice you're doing it after a while
well that happens um that yeah you
probably get this you'll be talking to
somebody and they'll think oh that's
weird you're the same person that I saw
do the show yeah meaning they assume
that you'll you become a different
person yes and um uh people are
always I'm I will I will do bits for
people endlessly in like an airport or
like a Taco Bell people be like why is
he why aren't you this like serious
quiet man in your regular life and then
youting Scott Ian from Anthrax never
wanting to speak to you the entire he
was trying to get away from me um wait
so are you so that was my whole thing
with my mom when I was like I recently I
guest hosted for Kimmel when he had Co
and so they were like why don't when he
said he had Co yeah when he said he had
wanted a little downtime and uh and so
and so they were like you should
interview your mom on video chat so I
interviewed my mom and I go mom what was
I like as a kid and she goes you you
were not funny you were so serious and
then she goes she goes you comedians are
so serious I was like how many comedians
do you
know you you texting Ronnie Chang yeah
turns out she knows a lot are you on an
email email email thread with Roy Wood
Jr like what's going on here Mom what
don't I know